c'est charolaises se nourrissent de
chapelure de pain dans cette ferme
expérimentale le nouvel aliment se
substitue à la ration alimentaire en
céréales il a été testé durant plusieurs
semaines sur les animaux
que chapelure donc on l'a on l'a fait
analyser au cours de l'essai on la
récolté on l'a fait analyser comme
n'importe quel type d'aliment pour les
animaux et ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on a
exactement la même qualité qu'un blé en
fait c'est normal puisque le pain est
fait à partir de blé donc on retrouve
vraiment cette qualité du blé donc ça
équivaut un blé
la chapelure est conditionnée ici dans
cet établissement par des adultes en
situation de handicap
la chaîne de transformation est en
capacité de conditionner 250 kg de pain
par heure du pain perdu que la banque
alimentaire de l'Indre récupère et
achemine plusieurs fois par semaine sur
le site
[Musique]
alors c'est la ramasse de ce matin dans
les boulangeries et GSM partenaires de
la Banque alimentaire et les trois
quarts de Spain qui est ramassé
finissait forcément à la poubelle donc
on a réfléchi longuement sur les
possibilités qu'on avait
qu'on pouvait développer pour arriver à
utiliser ce pain d'une façon ou d'une
autre et éviter de le jeter quoi
partenaire du projet l'entreprise
sociale et solidaire idem à investi
15000 euros dans la chaîne de
reconditionnement le recyclage du pain
apporte une nouvelle activité à
l'entreprise mais pas seulement
aujourd'hui dans toutes nos activités la
partie recyclage environnementale fait
partie de nos priorités et l'éducation
par rapport à ça on a besoin de
maintenir au quotidien
l'idée m'a entrepris de commercialiser
la chapelure de pin a un prix très
attractif 30% moins cher que les
aliments classiques à base de céréales
sujets à l'inflation depuis l'hiver
dernier
objectif nous c'est pas on n'est pas là
pour faire de l'argent mais par contre
l'objectif c'est que les agriculteurs
aussi s'y retrouvent parce que on sait
très bien que le cours des aliments a
aussi évolué pas dans le bon sens pour
eux donc de trouver une alternative
justement intéressante économiquement
les éleveurs commencent à montrer leur
intérêt
l'objectif à moyen terme est de
conditionner la chapelure dans des sacs
de 5 kg à destination des particuliers
pour ouvrir de nouveaux débouchés à la
chapelure de pain